qu'est-ce que c'est funky qui façonne mes cheveux je n'aime pas
faire ouais et bien nous devrons faire
des choses que nous n'aimons pas faire ce que nous
faisons, [ __ ], n'attends pas pour le donner,
je trouve toute communication très difficile,
Nathan est certainement d'un spectre de traits
de l'autisme est un jeune homme unique parce que
je ne parle pas beaucoup, les gens pensent que je
n'ai rien à dire et ce n'est pas vrai.
J'ai beaucoup de choses à dire après en
avoir conclu une que
vous avez menée avec succès au
Royaume-Uni et vous êtes  seize
des jeunes cerveaux les plus intelligents de ce
pays, il y a six places disponibles,
mais vous six êtes la vraie
compétition, ravi de vous rencontrer, mon nom est
stupide, peut-être que je suis le professeur de Nathan depuis sept
ans, c'est un enfant très sensible ou j'essaie
de vous glisser quelqu'un d'autre, c'est  ringard
tu sais je plaisantais
je sais que je suis un endroit étrange je pense que
je vois le monde d'une manière différente des
autres
tu vas faire des choses incroyables dans le
futur en charmant ton [ __ ]